JENNY BROWN: Powering your job
search with the Cloud Talent
Solution job search API
lets you start getting
quality results immediately.
However, there are plenty of
ways to tweak search requests
to match any business needs.
Let's look at some
configuration parameters
you can apply and test when
making a search request.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
To make the biggest impact
on the number and relevance
of jobs returned when
someone does a search, let's
look at two parameters you can
configure when making this API
search request--
enableBroadening and
disableKeywordMatch.
enablebroadening does
exactly what it sounds like.
It broadens the search
results that get returned.
It does this by relaxing
the restrictions
on location and job categories.
This is a binary
property for the search,
so it's either true or
false and defaults to false
if you don't set it yourself.
Setting it to true will give
more results to a search query
but may start to return
extended results that
aren't an exact match for
what the user searched for.
Don't worry.
The most relevant jobs
will still appear first.
The next property is
disableKeywordMatch,
which is another
binary property that
tells the search request
to return additional jobs
through keyword matching.
When set to false,
additional job
matches that aren't deemed
relevant by the ML algorithm
but do match the search
query string get returned.
Just like with enableBroadening,
disableKeywordMatch
defaults to false, and
any additional results
will appear lower than
those most relevant.
Let's look at what
happens when you
use enableBroadening and
disableKeywordMatch together.
This quick table
gives a general idea
of what users will
see in a search result
based on these parameters.
Again, the most
relevant search results
are always returned first.
Without changing anything,
a default search request
has enableBroadening
and disableKeywordMatch
set to false.
This leads to the
most relevant jobs
being followed by any jobs
that match the keyword search.
If you change
disableKeywordMatch to be true
but leave
enableBroadening as false,
your search results will
include only machine
learning recommended results
since Keyword Matching
and Broadening have
both been turned off.
This means only the most
relevant jobs are displayed,
but it's also the configuration
with the fewest number
of jobs returned.
Now if you flip these
and have enableBroadening
set to true and
disableKeywordMatch set
to false, you'll get
the maximum number
of jobs returned for a search.
The most relevant jobs will
be followed by keyword matched
and expanded query jobs.
Finally, if both
disableKeywordMatch and
enableBroadening or set
to true, search queries
will turn the most relevant
jobs followed by only
the expanded query results.
So you can see how
these two properties can
be used to influence jobs that
get returned from a search
query.
There's no right or
wrong configuration.
It just depends on
what makes the most
sense for your business case.
We recommend trying a few
different configurations
to see which works best
for you and your users.
Now that we've covered those
two parameters, let's look
at two more options you can use
to further refine the jobs that
show up in your user searches.
We'll look at featured
jobs and custom ranking
in the next video.
Thanks for watching
and remember,
when looking for talent, it's OK
to keep your head in the cloud.